A team of nine South African students and young professionals...
...won the first My Clean Green Home,...
...a local building and design competition.
The contest challenged designers to build a house...
...that produced no carbon emissions with a budget of just 12,000 dollars.
It's a good way to bring what we believe and what we study to the general public,...
...and to actually share this with the city of Cape Town and the festival...
...to actually educate people more about net-zero carbon buildings.
Despite the small size, just seven square meters,...
...the house quality surprised the public.
Being green is always expensive,...
...so it can't be rolled out to everybody,...
...but if this is sustainably, economically viable, then it makes a lot of sense.
Cape Town authorities say buildings consume 38 percent of the city's energy...
...and generate 58% of its carbon emissions.
They aim to have all new city buildings carbon neutral from 2030.